you've done a number of things through
your career already in the last 10 years
i believe um if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
well i don't know if that really has
anything to do with me but if there's
you know one project that
i would
recommend to people to see maybe i i
think maybe maybe it's the tree of life
uh if that was the first film i ever
worked on i was 11 years old i'm not you
know i don't have a big part in it or
anything but i think the movie is you
know watching it now uh as an adult uh
i think you know it's uh incredibly
moving
movie and um
i i think it also you know maybe i it's
a uh it was a very special time for me
the first time being on a film set so
that was exciting for me as well but i
don't know i might i might recommend
that that movie
yeah that that's a that's not a bad one
i i think i could i could i could
see that choice um uh you've worked with
a number of talented directors is i mean
some great directors um is there
something that all of them share that
you've noticed or are they all such
individuals that they're hard to
quantify like that
um
mostly it's hard to quantify but i think
that there is
definitely one
uh consistent
uh characteristic is that they all love
storytelling they all love stories they
all love
filmmaking and they're you know complete
film nerds um you know so
they you know you think you look at
somebody who's you know
been you know making amazing movies for
for decades now and
you think about how they get there and
you don't really know looking in from
the outside and you work with you know
one of these individuals and you realize
that they're they're just watching twice
as many movies as anybody else you know
and that's that's what gives them the
the upper hand so i think it's you know
i think it's hard work and it's focus
and you know and uh and then a
dedication to their to their craft and i
think that's pretty consistent across
across the board
uh for people that aren't familiar with
uh the tender bar what are you actually
most excited for people to see in the
movie um i think that you know i mean
really i think it's just the the the
the arc of of this this story and
you know that um it's based on memoir um
by by j.r moranger and uh it's uh you
know it's about about his his life i
play
jr or what you know the older version of
jr daniel renery plays the younger
version when he's
seven or eight years old in the movie um
but uh i think what i'm most excited is
just
you know this this i had a very personal
connection to this movie when i read the
script and i think that it is in a way a
bit of an underdog tale and you know
some of the more important themes and
things that i learned from the movie or
that you know you may be longing for
something like jr is longing for
you know
a father
you know that has been absent through
throughout his life and and uh i think
towards the end you know he has this
realization that everything he needs has
actually been there
all along and i think that's that's
a pretty important theme so i don't know
i think it's a very relatable story i
think people are going to get a lot out
of it it's a it's a journey film but
it's also about family and and uh you
know pursuing your dreams as well
i'm a big fan of bill monahan um i i
really think he's just such a talented
screenwriter what was it like reading i
mean obviously it's based on a book but
what was it like reading his words on
the page for the first time
well i kept
reading it and uh first off i was really
excited i was like wow like excited to
read the script you know i was a fan of
some of his work and and uh
started reading it i was like oh this is
really good you know and then
he kept reading and it's like oh it's
really good you know it's and then you
finish and you're like man it's not
often that you read a script that's it's
pretty much perfect and i you know i
definitely felt that about this this
screenplay so i think there was i was
excited on many different levels i was
excited
about the screenplay i was excited
george was directing it
you know ben was attached to play uncle
charlie uh when it came around to me
and uh yeah those were all all exciting
things so i i it was this movie has a
lot of heart to it and and uh i think
that i just you know felt a very
personal connection to it and really
just wanted to pursue in it and was
hoping you know that i could be a part
of it
uh obviously george is very talented
behind the camera very talented in front
of the camera he's you know kind of good
at his at his job um what what surprised
you about working with him and did he
give you any sort of directing notes
that you'd really never gotten before as
an actor
yes absolutely his i mean his style is
very
um i would say it's
like a lot of directors uh i've worked
with but then not like any at all
in the sense that you know sometimes the
direction where it's coming from is kind
of through the lens of an actor's
perspective
you know so he's very very engaged very
energetic um
you know obviously very charismatic guy
uh and you know you almost feel like uh
sometimes
the direction that he's giving you it's
like you're
you're almost on the same wavelength
you're acting the scenes out together
uh in a strange way so it was a really
really fun
dynamic that i never worked with an
actor director before so um that was
that was a lot of fun for me
i'm always curious about about is uh how
actors get ready for like a big scene so
hypothetically if you have something
that you know is going to be a tough
scene on like a monday how do you
actually like to prepare for a scene
like that um is it like a week out is it
days before
i'm just curious about your process
yeah i mean i think that's a good
question i mean whatever
it kind of depends on how much time you
have you know i think a lot of films
here you're shooting 12 hours a day
every day and every day is a big day you
know and um
so sometimes it's hard to
to find the time to to to prepare once
you're once you're in it you know
because uh it can be kind of like if you
know you got crazy tunnel vision you
can't do anything else except just be
focused on
on on
on making the film and
i think for this you know i was a bit
more the schedule had a bit more
breathing room for me and i kind of had
a little bit more time to work on some
of these scenes maybe um before we
we got there but i mean it's just you
know you sen you you come home uh you
know you you get ready the the usually
it's the weekend you know i take the
weekend and i look over all the scenes
that i have to shoot that that week and
i've kind of put five stars next to the
ones that are most important and if i
have some free time you know i spend my
time looking at those and trying to
digest them and
work them out
but really every day you know you come
home and you're just getting ready for
the next day because that's all you can
really focus on is what's right in front
of you
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say congrats i do hope the film is a
huge hit always great talking with you
yeah you too man thanks a lot i
appreciate it